I'M SENATOR BILL DODD CHAIRMAN
OF THE SENATE GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS TODAY WILL BE
HOLDING CON -- INFORMATION
HEARINGS ON TRIBAL STATE COMPACT.
OF BOTH HOOPER VALLEY TRIBE IN
THE SUSANVILLE INDIA AND
RANCHERIA.
BOTH THESE CONTACTS WERE SIGNED
ON OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR BY
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN.
IT S MY UNDERSTANDING THE BOTH
ARE SUPPORTED BY A CURRENT
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM. FOR THOSE
OF YOU UNFAMILIAR WITH THE
SENATE'S PROCEDURE.
ESTABLISHED POLICY ALLOWS FOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
ESSENCE OF THE COMPACT. TO BE
FOLLOWED BY A VOTE.
ON THE MEMBERS OF BUT OF THE
MEMBERS ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
THERE IS NO VOTE TAKEN AND
POLICY COMMITTEE HERE TODAY.
ALSO AS A REMINDER THE
LEGISLATURE'S IS NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO AMEND TRIBAL
COMPACTS.
THE VOTE THAT WILL BE TAKEN ON
THE SENATE FLOOR WILL BE SIMPLY
TO RATIFY THE COMPACT.
PLANNING PURPOSES WE WILL BEGIN
WITH UBER VALLEY FOLLOWED BY
SUSANVILLE.
LET ME THANK ALL THE WITNESSES
IN ADVANCE TODAY I ESPECIALLY
WANT TO THANK -- MISS NAY MARK --
FOR BEING HERE AND WELCOME YOU
TO TO THE FIRST OF WHAT I'M SURE
WILL BE -- PLENTY OF
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON TRIBAL --
CONTACTS IN THE COMING YEARS.
AFTER WE TAKE TESTIMONY FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS LISTED ON THE AGENDA
WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITYFOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
IF THE WITNESS FOR THE WHO THE
VALLEY COMPAQ AND PLEASE COME
FORWARD SO WE CAN BEGIN.
SHERMAN PLEASE MORNING HONORABLE
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS RYAN JACKSON AND THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE VALLEY TRIBE.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF A SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY
FOUR WHICH WILL RATIFY.
AN AMENDMENT TO THE VALLEY
TRIBES GAMING COMPACT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WE WISH TO THANK SENATOR MCGUIRE
FOR AS LONG TIME SUPPORT OF THE
VALLEY TRIBE AS WILLINGNESS TO
SPONSOR A RATIFICATION BILL --
BELLY TRIBUNAL COUNTY HAS ONE OF
THE LARGEST TRUST LAND BASES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
TROUBLE MEMBERS.
TRY BUSINESSES INCLUDE ARBOR
MANY MARK.
AL UTILITIES DISTRICT.
THEY ONE ALDEN IN MOTEL
[inaudible]
CASINO.
UBER FORCE INDUSTRIES.
THESE BUSINESSES ARE CRUCIAL TO
THE TRIBES ECONOMY AS A PROVIDE
GOOD SERVICES.
AND JOBS TO THE COMMUNITY. TO
ENSURE THAT LOOK AMERICAN SINGLE
CAN CONTINUE TO OPERATE SLOT
MACHINES.
SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR CODIFIES
EXISTING COMPACT THAT THE VALLEY
TRIBE AGREED UPON WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR.
TODAY THE WHO REALLY TRIBE IS
DRIVING WITH APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE TRIBAL MEMBERS.
THE TRIBE OWNS SEVERAL
ENTERPRISES THAT OPERATE ON THE
RESERVATION.
INCLUDING LUCKY BEAR CASINO.
ALL ACT AS AN INTEGRAL PART OF
THE VALLEY'S ECONOMY.
THE CASINO CURRENTLY OPERATES
BETWEEN EIGHTY AND A HUNDRED
THIRTY MACHINES ON THE GAMING.
FOR AND HAS TWENTY EMPLOYEES TWO
OF WHICH ARE WHO PUT TRAVEL
MEMBERS.
THE LAST CONTACT WAS RATIFIED IN
SEPTEMBER.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE TRIBES CONTACT WAS
BRIEF UPON WITH GOVERNOR BROWN.
THIS BILL COMBAT CODIFIES THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TRAVEL COMPACT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
VALLEY TRIBE.
SO THEY CAN OPERATE THE LUCKY
BEAR CASINO.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE TRIBE OPERATE UP TO
THREE HUNDRED FORTY NINE GAMING
MACHINES AND HAVE UP TO TWO
CASINOS ON THE TRIBES TRUST
LANDS.
THE COMPACT INCLUDES UPDATED
PROVISIONS FOR LICENSING
COMPLIANCE ENFORCEMENT.
MEDICATION OF OFFERS A VISION
IMPACTS.
PROTECTIONS FOR PATRONS
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE.
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER RECENT
CONTACTS.
BECAUSE THE TRIBES LANDS ARE
EXTREMELY REMOTE.
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO OFFERS
VACATION IMPACT OF THE TRIBE'S
CASINO.
THIS COMPACT AMENDMENT WILL
ALLOW THE TRIBE TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE A SMALL GAMING FACILITY.
FOR ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THE STATE HAS AGREED TO WAIVE
THE COST OF REGULATORY FEES TO
THE STATE FOR FIVE YEARS.
IS A LUCKY BEAR CASINO SO SMALL
AND IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT
THE TRIBE AGREED.
UPDATE THE REGULATORY PROVISIONS
FROM THE NINETEEN NINETY NINE
CONTACT.
IS OUR HOPE THAT WITH THE
PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN LAST YEAR
THAT WE WILL NOT BE OBLIGATED TO
PAY REGULATORY COSTS IN THE
FUTURE.
INCREASED COST OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE UPDATED REGULATORY-PROVISIONS I HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON CASINO REVENUES WHICH
PROVIDE JOBS TO TRIBAL MEMBERS.
THE STATE RECOGNIZE THE TRIBE
SHOULD NOT BE REQUIRED TO PAY
REGULATORY COSTS IN LIGHT OF THE
BURDEN WOULD HAVE ON THE TRIBE.
AND IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT
THE TRIBE DID NOT PAY SUCH COSTS.
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS.
THE TRIBES REGULATORY ABILITY
HAS PROVEN TO BE MORE THAN
ADEQUATE TO ENSURE THAT THE
GAMING FACILITY.
IS OPERATED IN A MANNER THAT
PROTECTS PUBLIC SAFETY AND
INSURERS INTEGRITY OF THE GAMING
CONDUCTED THERE AND YOUR PLEASE
A GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND HIS NEW
TRAVEL NEGOTIATOR AND A NAY MARK.
OUR SUPPORT OF THIS FRAMEWORK
AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SB.
SIX SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THEY MARK.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DODD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
I MY NAME IS ANNA NAY MARKHAM
THAT -- TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS
ADVISER FOR GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM IT'S ALSO AN HONOR TO BE
SITTING UP HERE WITH -- JACKSON
OF THE HOOPA TRIBE.
AND THE TRIBE IN THE STATE
ENTERED INTO A TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHICH
ENABLE THE TRIBES TO REVENUES%
GENERATED BY ITS CASINO TO
SUPPORT A STRONG SELF SUFFICIENT
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT.
AND TO FIND ESSENTIAL SERVICES
TO TRIBAL CITIZENS.
IN LIGHT OF THAT OF THE UPCOMING
BROWN ADMINISTRATION NEGOTIATED
AND SIGNED A NEW CONTACT WITH
THE WHO BUT DR.
IT'S COMPACT SUPPORTS TRIBAL IN
STATE INTERESTS AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE RECENT
COMPACTS RATIFIED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE TO THE NEWSMEN
MINISTER.
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS ITS
RATIFICATION.
THE ECONOMIC PROVISIONS ALLOW
FOR THE TRIBE TO OPERATE UP TO
THREE HUNDRED FORTY NINE GAMING
DEVICES IN UP TO TWO FACILITIES.
CONTACT REQUIRES A TRIED TO PAY
ITS PRO RATA SHARE SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND COSTS THOSE
WILL BE DELAYED UNTIL -- TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND AS THE CHAIRMAN
MENTIONED -- UNDER THE AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN I THINK IS --
THERE IS DISCRETION BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO HAVE
THEM NOT PAY THAT AT ALL IF
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT FUNDS IN THE
STF.
I'M SO THAT GIVES SOME SORT OF
BUFFER SPACE FOR THAT.
AT THE TOP OF THE TRIBE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUNDING
WINSTEAD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PAYMENTS UNDER THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND.
AND THE TRIBAL NATIONS GRANT
FUND.
THE OTHER CORE PROVISIONS OF THE
COMPACT INCLUDING TERMS RELATED
TO LICENSING REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR T THOSE AND OTHER
CONTACTS NEGOTIATED BY THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION.
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THIS INCLUDES
PROTECTIONS AGAINST WORKPLACE
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
PROVISIONS TO ADOPT TO COMPLY
WITH A FAIRLY VERSUS FEDERAL
FAIR LABOR STANDARDS ACT.
AND INCLUSION OF THE STATE'S
MINIMUM WAGE RATES TRIBAL ADOPT
THE STANDARD TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE.
CONTACT ALSO INCLUDE SIMILAR
PROVISIONS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION BASIN TERMINATION F
IMPACTS IN THE TRIBAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
COMPAQ'S TERM IS TWENTY FIVE
YEARS UNLIKE THE NINETY NINE
WHICH IS -- TWENTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
AND TASTIC [inaudible]
MISTER GRIFFIN.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACK
RIBBON I REPRESENT UNITE HERE
THE HOTEL AND CASINO WORKERS
UNION.
THAT IS RECENTLY -- SURPASSES.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
MARK IN IT AND WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF THAT.
WE'RE ALSO PROUD OF THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT PIVOTED AWAY FROM THE FOR
ADMINISTRATION BEFORE THAT AND
DECIDED NOT TO TRY TO FIND.
PART OF THE GENERAL BUDGET THE
GENERAL -- FIND.
THROUGH TRIBAL GAMING -- AND WE
FEEL THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
TRIBES WHATEVER MONIES THEY
BRINGING SHOULD BE THEIR MONEY.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT THOUGH
WE ALSO ENJOYED THE FACT -- AND
APPRECIATED THE FACT THAT --
GOVERNOR BROWN.
TOOK AN INTEREST IN THE WORKERS
WHO ARE NOT MEMBERS OF THE OWNER
TRIED.
AND ENSURED THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
THE RIGHTS.
TO FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND FREEDOM
OF ASSOCIATION.
AND JOIN A UNION SHOULD THEY
DECIDE TO DO THAT AT SOME POINT.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT WE
THOUGHT WAS SINCE THEY ARE THE
ENGINE BEHIND THIS INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S GROWN QUITE
LARGE.
THAT THAT WAS ALSO A VERY VERY --
ADMIRABLE THING FOR THE LAST
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION TO DO
AND WE ARE NOW PLEASE THAT THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION.
SEEMS TO BE I'M INTERESTED IN
TAKING THE SAME COURSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER RAYMOND -- FROM
MY STANDPOINT A LOT OF QUESTIONS
OF ALREADY BEEN ASKED ANSWERED
ANY MEMBERS -- WHEN YOU DRESS
ANY ISSUE?
I JUST WANT.
TO CENTER RUBIO PLEASE.
I THINK I MISSED THAT HE SAID
THAT AROUND A SHARE IS GONNA BE
LATE.
YES THAT'S CORRECT.
I JUST.
YEAH I KNOW IT'S IF IT'S IF IT'S
HELPFUL CLARIFICATION IT'S A BIT
SORT OF CONFUSING BECAUSE I'M
THE CONTACTED DOES PROVIDE FOR
PRO RATA SHARE.
BUT RECOGNIZING THE SIZE OF THE
CASINO AND WANTING TO ENSURE
THAT -- ANY FUNDS FROM THE
CASINO GO BACK TO THE TRIBE AND
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS.
THEY BECAUSE THIS THERE'S THIS
SORT OF THE A. B. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN WHICH ALLOWS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO REDUCE
OR COMPLETELY ELIMINATE PAYMENTS
FOR LIMITED GAMING TRIBES.
AND I THINK WHAT AS I UNDERSTAND
IT THEY SORT OF PUT THE THE
DELAYED TO JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE INTO THE COMPACT.
SO THERE WOULD BE SOME TIME TO
KIND OF WORK THAT ALL OUT AND
THE FOR THE TRIBE WOULD HAVE TO
PAY ANY AS THE F. FUND SO IT
WOULDN'T BE JUST SORT OF A A
CLIFF FOR SUDDENLY THEY HAD TO
PAY A NEW FEES THAT THEY DIDN'T.
SERENA.
THERE ARE TWO A YES.
THANK YOU CONGRATULATIONS FOR
THE WORK YOU DO I SEE THAT THAT
THAT THAT -- THE TRIBE HAS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE AND ROLLED
MEMBERS A LOS TRIBE MEMBERS OF
THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS HOUSE AT
NUMBER.
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED OTHERS ARE
ALL TRIBAL MEMBERS YEAH ALL
PRIVATE MEMBERS.
AND AND ALSO I I ALSO SEE THAT
THE WORK THAT WE DO GO BACK INTO
NOT ONLY THE CASINO BUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY -- TO TAKE CARE OF
COURSE THE TRIBAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
THE VOCATIONAL TRAINING
EDUCATIONAL HEAD START PROGRAM
AND SOME OF THE OTHER.
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS THAT YOU GET
BACK IN YOUR LIFE ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT YOU GIVE BACK.
TO YOUR OWN COMMUNITY AND HOW IT
AFFECTS THE OUTSIDE COMMUNITY.
SURE I WOULD I WOULD HIGHLIGHT
THAT -- THE VALLEY TRIBE IS ONE
OF THE ORIGINAL SELF GOVERNANCE
TRIBES OF FORMED IN. NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT UNDER THE INDIAN
SELF DETERMINATION AND EDUCATION
ASSISTANCE ACT.
DAN LOUDEST -- TO CONTACT WITH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GIVING A FAIR
SPECIFICALLY.
ALL THE GOVERNMENTAL FUNCTIONS
THAT -- WERE REQUIRED AS A
RESULT OF TREATIES ARE SIGNED IN
THE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
OF FROM THAT POINT ON UNTIL NOW
IT'S BEEN THE TRIBES OF
POSSIBILITIES PROVIDE.
OF ALL THE SERVICES THAT --
FOLKS WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE LAW
YOU OFFER THE RESERVATION SO I
COULD MENTION BEFORE.
I EDUCATION IS ONE AREA WE O
FIND A LOT OF THE SCHOLARSHIPS
AND AND GRANT AWARDS FOR FOR
STUDENTS -- WE COME IN A LOT OF
THE MONEY INTO OUR RECREATIONAL
PROGRAMS -- DIVERSION OR
OTHERWISE OF FOR OUR YOUTH.
ARE THERE OTHER NUMBER OF OTHER
AREAS THAT WE ALSO -- SPAN AND
COMMIT OUR DOLLARS -- TO ACROSS
THE BOARD SOCIAL SERVICES -- I
WAS ALSO -- YOU KNOW.
IN WHICH THE FUNDS ARE USED TO
HELP AGREE MORE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES FORCE
AS WELL SO.
WE TRIED -- TO SPREAD AROUND AS
MUCH AS WE CAN TO TRY AN IMPACT --
MAJORITY OF THE MEMBERS ON THE
RESERVATION.
AS FAR AS IMPACTS TO THE FOLKS
THAT ARE -- NOT A PART OF THE
TRIBE IF YOU WILL BUT ARE THE
OVERALL.
COMMUNITY WE'RE VERY INCLUSIVE
OF EVERYONE WHO'S THERE --
OBVIOUSLY IF IF YOU'RE NOT A
TRIBAL MEMBER NOT NECESSARILY
ENTITLED AS SOME OF THE SERVICES
OR BENEFITS THAT WE DO PROVIDE.
A MORE HEALTH CARE FACILITY IS
OPEN TO ANYONE WHO.
YOU KNOW NEEDS ANY KIND OF
ASSISTANCE AND IN THAT WAY SO.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT WE
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE TOO MUCH OF
AN IMPACT ON ON THE COMMUNITY
OUTSIDE OF US AND IF THAT WERE
THE CASE AND WE WILL TRY TO
REMEDY THAT IF THERE WERE ANY
ISSUES THAT THAT DID ARISE.
THE IMPACTED YOU IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE OUTSIDE WOULD BE THE
EMPLOYMENT.
OF OF MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
WHO ARE ABLE TO BE.
PART OF THE ORGANIZATION AS FAR
AS EMPLOYEES.
THERE'S THAT AND THEN THERE'S
ALSO THE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
TOURISM AS WELL FOLKS THAT DO
COME IN YOU KNOW WHAT WE LIVE
FOR THEM TO FRIEDMAN ARE STATUS
MEN AND ENJOYING THE VALLEY IS
AS WE DO AS WELL. FOR THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY IS IS REAPING THE WILL
ROARED SHOULD OBVIOUSLY.
FROM THE CASINO AS WELL BECAUSE
OF THE EMPLOYEES BEING ABLE.
TO OF LIVE AROUND THE COMMUNITY
AND AND BY HOMES AND PARTICIPATE
IN.
AND THE THINGS THAT THEY DO --
ON THEIR DAILY LIVES SHOPPING
AND AND JUST BEING -- A WELL OF
ORGANIZING MANAGE ORGANIZATION
THAT YOU ARE THEY'RE ABLE TO
HAVE A STABLE INCOME.
ABLE JOBS FOR THE FUTURE AND SO
ON AS WELL ABSOLUTELY.
PLEASE I'M MY NAME'S PAIN I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE HELP OF VALLEY
TRIBE AND I JUST WANTED TO MAYBE
CLARIFY WHEN. ONE POINT FOR
EVERYONE BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT OF
THE CONTACTS THAT COME BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN ARE
LARGE GAMING TRIBES THAT HAVE
MAYBE SMALL TRIBAL LANDS.
AND YOU KNOW THAT ARE WITHIN A
LARGER COMMUNITY BUT THEY HAVE A
VALLEY TRIBE THEY'RE EXTREMELY
RURAL AND THE RENT THE
RESERVATION AREA IS VERY LARGE.
AND SO THE WHO THE LUCKY BEAR
CASINO IS A VERY SMALL FACILITY
HAS.
USUALLY UNDER A HUNDRED MACHINES
AND IT IS JUST REALLY ADD UP AN
AMENITY THAT IS IN THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY WITHIN THE RESERVATION
IT DOES PROVIDE LIMITED NUMBER
OF JOBS TO TRIBAL MEMBERS.
AS A IT REALLY.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE A AN OFF
RESERVATION IMPACT FROM THE
CASINO BECAUSE THE DISTANCES SO
GREAT.
SO -- IT IS UNUSUAL IN THAT
SENSE AND I THINK THAT AS I
WANTED TO JUST CLARIFY THAT
BECAUSE GOING FORWARD MANY OF
THIS THESE CONTACTS FOR LIMITED
GAMING TRIBES THAT HAVE FEWER
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MACHINES.
THEY WILL BE THAT KIND OF TRIBE
WHERE THEY HAVE LESS OF AN
INTERACTION WITH THE LOCAL.
BECAUSE THEIR SELF CONTAINED AND
SELF GOVERNED I'M AND BUT DO
CONTINUE TO HAVE POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE COUNTY.
OF THE STATE AND I AM THE CASINO
REALLY ISN'T THE ECONOMIC ENGINE
OF THE TRIBE.
BUT IT PROVIDED NO JOBS TO THE
TRIBAL MEMBERS AND OTHERS THAT
WANT TO WORK THERE.
THANK YOU FOR SHARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS POINT
TIME WE'RE GONNA GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ANY BODY WISHING TO
COMMENT ON THIS COMPACT
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THAT COMPLETES THE THE THE
HEARING -- FOR YOU WE APPRECIATE
THIS THIS WILL AS I SAID EARLIER --
WILL END UP -- BACK IN THE
SENATE -- FOR OR APPROVAL SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
NOW WILL BEGIN THE THE COMPACT
HEARING FOR THE SUSANVILLE
INDIAN RANCHERIA.
AND WE'LL START WITH YOU.
THEY MARK [inaudible]
HELLO AGAIN.
OF AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
HAVING ME.
AND AS WITH THE THE WHO THE
CONTACTS THE TRIBE IN THE STATE
ENTERED INTO A TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACTS.
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHICH
SIMILARLY TO WHO BY AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR REPEATING MYSELF
BUT I THINK IT'S WORTH NOTING --
THROUGH REVENUES GENERATED BY
ITS THE SCENE NO SUPPORTS A
STRONG SELF SUFFICIENT TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT AND FUNDS ESSENTIAL
SERVICES -- TRIBAL CITIZENS.
IN LIGHT OF THIS OF THE UPCOMING
EXPIRATION OF THAT CONTACT THE
BROWN ADMINISTRATION NEGOTIATED
AND SIGNED A NEW CONTRACT WITH
THE SUSANVILLE TRIBE.
IS COMPLEX IMPORTS TRIBAL AND
STATE INTERESTS AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH RECENT CONTACTS
RATIFIED BY THIS LEGISLATURE AND
SO THE NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORTS ITS RATIFICATION.
THE ECONOMIC PROVISIONS ALLOW
FOR THE TRIBE TO OPERATE UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED GAMING DEVICES IN
UP TO TWO FACILITIES.
COME BACK REQUIRES THE TRIBE
PAYSPRO RATA SHARE SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND COSTS.
THE TRIBE IS NOT REQUIRED TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND BUT IF IT
DECIDES TO GO ABOVE THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE DEVICES.
IT WILL NO LONGER BE CONSIDERED
A LMITED GAMING TRIBE AND IT
WILL NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND OR
THE TRIBAL NATIONS GRANT FUNDS.
OTHER CORE PROVISIONS OF THIS
COMPACT OR SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
TO THE PROVISIONS I DESCRIBED
EARLIER IN WHO BY INCLUDING
TERMS REALLY TO LICENSING
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY --
TERM ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
I HAD THE TRIBES HOTELS
FREQUENTED BY HUNTERS -- SO THE
SUSANVILLE COMPACT HAS A UNIQUE
PROVISION THAT IN ADDITION TO
THE NORMAL PROHIBITION ON NON
LAW ENFORCEMENT POSSESSION OF
WEAPONS AT A GAMING FACILITY.
IT ALLOWS OVERNIGHT GUESTS AT
THE HOTEL TO TRANSPORT AND STORE
UNLOADED WEAPONS AND AMMUNITION
IN THEIR HOTEL ROOMS.
SO THAT'S SORT OF THE BIG THE
BIG UNIQUE THING WITH THIS
COMPACT THAT'S WORTH NOTING --
IN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS IS ALSO AN
HONOR TO BE HERE WITH THE
TOURNAMENTS I WANNA AKE SURE
ANYTHING -- WHEN BEAUVAIS?
YES.
MORNING.
I AM SICK.
SO SORRY.
BUT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO BE HERE
TODAY WITH ALL OF YOU AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M CHAIRMAN DODD AND THE REST
OF THE OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I AM I AM DOING ABOVE AND THE
CHAIR WOMAN FOR THE SUSANVILLE
INDIAN RANCHERIA.
OUR TRIBE IS LOCATED IN
SUSANVILLE CALIFORNIA WITHIN
LASSEN COUNTY HOUSING COUNTY IS
A VERY LARGE GEOGRAPHICAL COUNTY.
ALTHOUGH IT'S A VERY SMALL
POPULATED RURAL AREA.
AND WE ARE.
WE ARE WITHIN THE CASKET IS HERE
NEVADA MOUNTAIN RANGES -- OUR
TRIBE IS UNIQUE IN THAT THEY
CONSIST OF HI MY TO PIT RIVER
AND WASH SO TRIBES THERE. FOR
FOUR SEPARATE TRIES.
THE TRIBAL PEOPLE THAT OUR MAKE
UP OUR POPULATION.
OF THIS IS A MILLION RANCHERIA.
OUR TRIBE IS COMPRISED OF ABOUT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS.
ARE MEMBERS I'M.
WE HAVE SOME THAT ARE IN CANADA
THEY'RE SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES.
I'M.
A RESERVATION HAS GROWN STEADILY
FROM THIRTY ACRES IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED ACRES TODAY.
BROUGH AND DONATIONS PURCHASES
FEDERAL LAND TRANSFERS AND SUCH.
LASSEN COUNTY IS EXTREMELY WORLD
ARE AND MENTION.
RATES.
PROXIMATE ONLY 16% AND A LOW PER
CAPITA INCOME OF ONLY
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THOUSAND
PER YEAR FOR THE US CENSUS
BUREAU.
ACCORDING TO THE US CENSUS
BUREAU AS OF TWO TWENTY SIXTEEN
THERE WERE ONLY THREE HUNDRED
NINETY EIGHT EMPLOYERS AND
LASSEN COUNTY [inaudible]
I'M.
THE TRIBE IS OPERATED THE
DIAMOND MOUNT CASINO SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND HAS
GRADUALLY.
EXPANDED THE INITIAL SIX
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT FACILITY AT
IN A RESTAURANT HOTEL.
AND MOST AND MOST RECENTLY A
MICROBREWERY -- THE CASINOS OUT
A POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE EC
ECONOMY OF THE REGION.
AND THE COMMUNITY OF THE REGION.
THE CASINOS EVENT SPACE.
SPACES HOST MULTITUDE OF FUND
RAISERS AND COMMUNITY EVENTS.
I'M WE WE ALSO HOLD A QUARTERLY
LAW ENFORCEMENT COALITION
MEETING.
WHERE WE INVITE?
MEMBERS OF THE LOCAL CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT ARE COUNTY --
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
WE HAVE OUR THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL COME.
OR SERVICE OF FISH AND GAME WE
HAVE A BE A LAW ENFORCEMENT --
WE HAVE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THE COMES UP.
AND WE DO THAT WE USED TO DO
THIS ON A I ANNUAL BASIS BUT NOW
WE'VE.
A MOVE THAT UP TO QUARTERLY
[inaudible]
AS WE SEE THAT YOU KNOW IN THIS
IS TIMES EVOLVE AND AND THINGS
ARE HAPPENING.
THROUGHOUT THE ARE A LASSEN
COUNTY -- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE THAT.
COLLABORATION ONGOING
COLLABORATION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- THAT THEY SEE US
AS MUCH OF A PARTNER AS WE DO
THEM -- IN -- GARNER THE TIMES
OF US AGAINST THEM TYPE OF
THINKING.
AND SO WE WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY
TO COLLABORATE WITH OUR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I MEAN REVENUES ARE.
VITAL FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE
TRIBES GOVERNMENT.
IN REVENUE SUPPORTS VITAL
PROGRAMS SUCH AS EDUCATION CHILD
CARE AND ELDER SERVICES FOR THE
TRIBES MEMBERS.
I'M ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
WE DO IS WE SPEND ABOUT. THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
ON HIGHER EDUCATION GRANTS FOR
TRIBAL MEMBERS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE -- AT LEAST
ONE MEMBER WHO IS IN HER
DOCTORATE PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS.
AND WE'RE VERY VERY PROUD OF
SHE'S -- SHE'S OF A YOUNGER
PERSON AND SHE'S WORKING.
VERY HARD TO BE ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT.
I AM WE WE PROMOTE.
WE'RE VERY PROUD AND WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE ALL OF OUR USED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT
EDUCATION IS.
THE TRIBES GAMING ENTERPRISES.
ENTERPRISE ALSO PROVIDES
EMPLOYMENT FOR UNDER THIRTY NINE
PEOPLE UNDER SIX OF WHICH ARE
NOT MEMBERS OF THE TRIBE.
AND THEY ARE COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
FOR THE MORE THE DIAMOND MOUNT
CASINO GIVES AWAY.
THE PROXIMUS APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
I'M TO LOCAL CHARITABLE CAUSES.
THIS LAST YEAR WHEN WE HAD THE
THE BIG FIRES IN OUR AREAS.
OUTSIDE OF OUR AREA.
BUT ON THE PARADISE -- FIRE.
AND THE TRIBES ALL THE YOU KNOW
THIS WAS SUCH A DEVASTATING
EVENT.
FOR PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE TRIBAL
MEMBERS THAT LIVE IN THAT AREA
AS WELL.
AND OUR LOCAL IN OR OTHER SISTER.
TRIBES.
THAT -- WE'VE PUT TOGETHER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
DONATED IT TO THIS BECAUSE I'M
TO THE VICTIMS.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WE DIDN'T PUT
THAT OUT IN THE NEWS WE DIDN'T.
DO ANYTHING WITH OTHER THAT IT
WAS MORE IMPORTANT TO JUST GIVE
WHAT WE COULD.
AND TRY AND HELP THE COMMUNITY
AND NOT USE IT IS SOME BIG
PUBLICITY EVENT -- THE TRIBE
ALSO PAYS THE CITY IS SUSANVILLE --
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND EACH
YEAR.
TO COSTA SERVICES PROVIDED --
FOR THEIR SERVICE TO THE CASINO
AND THE TRIBE.
WE ARE CURRENTLY.
HAS A STATED WE ARE NOT ONLY
COOPERATE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT WE'VE BEEN IN A VERY CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THE CITY OF
SUSANVILLE.
AS OUR CASINO IS LOCATED IN THE
CITY LIMITS.
AND WE ARE CURRENTLY LOOKING AT
PURCHASING TO ON OF THESE
VEHICLES. FOR THE CITY OF
SUSANVILLE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY'RE IN OUR
TALKS.
YOU KNOW THE CITY IS A SMALL
AGAIN VERY SMALL CITY.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY TO YOU KNOW TO PURCHASE
THEIR OWN.
THINGS AND SO WE THOUGHT THAT IT
WAS IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO TRY
AND HELP -- YOU KNOW THEY'LL
PROBABLY PUT SUSANVILLE INDIAN
RANCHERIA IN A VEHICLE PURCHASE
PRICE IS MILLION RANCHERIA.
BUT WE SEE THAT ALSO AS I'M AS A
PROMOTION THAT WE ARE.
WORKING IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE CITY OF SUSANVILLE.
WHICH IS IMPORTANT.
THE TRIBE CURRENTLY OPERATES IS
GIVEN FACILITY UNDER NINETEEN
NINETY NINE TRAVEL STATE GAMING
COMPACT.
WHICH IS SET TO EXPIRE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE WOULD ALLOW THE TRIBE. TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IS SMALL
GAMING FACILITY -- WHICH IS
RIGHT NOW ONLY OPERATE IN ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED GAMING DEVICES --
UNDER THE NEW TRAVELS TO COME.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME.
I THANK YOU ENTER ONE APPRECIATE
THAT -- NOW -- MISTER RUBIN'S
COMMENTS PLEASE.
YES AGAIN I'M MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACK
RIBBON WITH UNITE HERE THE HOTEL
AND CASINO WORKERS UNION. FOR
THE REASONS I DESCRIBED BEFORE.
WE SUPPORT THE SUSANVILLE.
RANCHERIA COMPACT JUST AS WE
SUPPORT THE HOOVER VALLEY --
TRIBES COMPACT AND WE WILL
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE ENTIRE
LABOR MOVEMENT.
MAKING SURE THAT BOTH THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY KNOW.
THAT WE SUPPORT THESE CONTACTS
AND WE HOPE THAT -- THESE
CONTACTS ACHIEVE UNANIMOUS VOTE
BOTH HOUSES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GRIFFIN --
QUESTIONS COMMENTS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
I'M.
SURE WOMAN -- I'M WONDERING --
CAN YOU DESCRIBE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE TRIBE STILL
FACES -- MOVING FORWARD PLEASE
WELL IT'S SO FOR IN -- IN
LOOKING AT IT I MEAN.
OUR OUR CASINOS SMALL.
NO WE DON'T WE DON'T.
MAKE A LOT OF MONEY [inaudible]
I'M.
WE DO IT WE'RE VERY FRUGAL WE DO
NOT GIVE CAPITA TO OUR TRIBAL
MEMBERS -- WE USE EVERY PENNY
THAT WE RECEIVE -- TO PUT BACK
INTO TROUBLE PROGRAMS.
AND SO IN A WITHOUT IT.
I'M AYE I DON'T KNOW WE WOULDN'T
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT.
OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS AS WELL AS WE
DO OUR HIGHER EDUCATION --
GRANTS AND AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW WITH
EVERYTHING.
I'M.
WE WE WORK.
LIKE I SAID IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THE CITY SO
THAT WE CAN -- OPERATE A VERY
WELL RAN CASINO [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
WE HAVE BANNED.
MANY MANY -- UNITY MEMBERS AS OF
DRUGS AND BECAUSE OF ALL KINDS
OF THINGS.
THE UGLY IN ALL THINGS THAT COME
IN.
RUNNING THE BAR IN YOU KNOW IN A
CASINO -- BUT WE IF WE KEEP OUR
EYES OPEN AND WE WATCH THOSE
THINGS.
AND WE'RE VERY EAGER TO REACT
AND KEEP OUR FACILITY A VERY
WELL.
IRAN'S SAFE PLACE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
OTHER THING THAT I WANTED TO SAY --
ALSO WITH OUR HOTEL WE ARE A
GREEN HOTEL.
AND WE'RE THE ONLY GREEN HOTEL
IN THE AREA SO THE STATE.
ACTUALLY -- WE HAVE QUESTIONS
AND CDF.
IN ALL SORTS OF THANK YOU FOR
SERVICE THEY COME IN STAY THERE
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE I'M
JUST STOP AND FORGIVE ME FOR NOT
KNOWING THIS CAN GIVE ME A SENSE
OF HOW YOU PLAN FOR THE FUTURE.
WE KNOW ALL THE OTHER.
TRIBES HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
GROWING THEIR THEIR HOTELS IN
THEIR INDUSTRY.
DO YOU SAID LIKE A LONG TERM
PLAN FOR YOUR OWN CASINO IN
TERMS OF WHERE THE INVESTMENTS
GOAL JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY.
CURRENTLY I AM IT'S JUST SO WE
AGAIN WE HAVE TO BE VERY HONEST
WITH OURSELVES.
ABOUT OUR PARKING POPULATION ARE
YOU KNOW THE WE HAVE
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW GONE A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION AND I HAD A LOT OF
THINGS AND IF THEY DIDN'T.
YOU KNOW HAVING BANDS ARE HAVING
IN -- THESE KINDS OF THINGS.
I'M.
THEY DIDN'T WORK OUT SO WE HAD
WE HAD PROBLEMS WITH FIGHTS AND
PEOPLE DRINKING TOO MUCH -- WE
SCALE BACK DOWN.
I DON'T SEE US BUILDING ANOTHER
CASINO.
I'M MORE WE'RE LOCATED.
AND I THINK THAT WE WILL.
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT
FACILITY AND CONTINUE TO JUST --
WHAT IT EVOLVE AND LOOKINGAT --
HOW WE CAN MARKET IT?
WE CONTINUE TO MARKET IT AS WELL
AS WE CAN -- WE PROBABLY ON THE
AREA THAT WE HAVE -- OUR HOTEL
PROBABLY WILL STAY THE SAME SIZE.
WE HAVE A GAS STATION MINI MART
ON TEIR PROPERTY.
AS WELL -- AND IF THEY THINK
THAT IT'S REALLY GOING TO REMAIN
THE SAME.
I DON'T SEE US ENLARGING OR
BUILDING ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THANK YOU
TERM.
I MISS NAY MARK NOT SPECIFIC TO
THE SUSANVILLE -- COMPACT BUT
WITH THE ON THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS WITH THE NINETEEN NINETY
NINE COMPACTS EXPIRY DO YOU HAVE
ANY IDEA OF HOW MANY -- COMPACTS
WILL BE SEEING THIS COMMITTEE
WILL BE SAYING.
YES OF COURSE -- TRIBES THAT ARE
NOT CURRENTLY GAMING COULD COME
FORWARD AND AND WANT TO
NEGOTIATE CONTACTS AS WELL BUT
ASSUMING THE ONLY THINGS THAT
WERE NEGOTIATING -- BEFORE THE
SORT OF DROP DEAD DATE OF I
THINK IT'S JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO RIGHT BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE EXPIRATION.
IN DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY AND
THEN THERE'S THE KIND OF
AUTOMATIC EXT -- IN NEGOTIATIONS
I BELIEVE THAT NUMBER IS
[inaudible]
THIRTY THREE YEAH.
THE OTHER COMMENTS [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT -- ONE IS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ROBERT
JOSEPHINUM THE DISTRICT TO
COUNCILMEMBER FOR THE CIVIL
INDIAN RANCHERIA.
OF ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
REALLYREALLY WANT TO LOOK AT IS
IS WE DONE A SURVEY FOR A FEW
YEARS AGO ON WHAT WE PUT BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITY THROUGH OUR
TAXES AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
WELL WE GOT ABOUT NINETY
EMPLOYEES AND VERY LITTLE OR
TRAVEL MEMBERS THERE -- SO A LOT
OF THE STATE AND FEDERAL TAXES
DO GO BACK OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY WHICH IS HUGE.
BUT I THINK MY BIGGEST THING IS
IS WE DON'T GIVE PER CAPITA JUST
LIKE HER TRAVEL CHARGER STATED.
YOU KNOW WE PUT IT BACK IN
EDUCATION.
EDUCATION OUR OUR OUR GOAL IS
YOU KNOW SELF SUFFICIENCY FOR
TRAVEL MEMBERS.
ARM WE HAVE BEEN IN I CALLED
THIS MORNING JUST DOUBLE CHECK
WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTY PEOPLE
AUTHOR RIGHT NOW THAT ARE THAT
ARE IN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM.
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS WE HAVE A
BOTTOM 95% SUCCESS RATE OF THOSE
GUYS MOVING ON TO ME THAT'S HUGE.
YOU KNOW ALL IN IN IN THE AND
THAT'S WERE YOU KNOW OUR OUR
MONEY GOES INTO -- THAT THE KIDS
THE ELDERS IN IN ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS I WANT TO PUT OUT
IS. FOR THE FIRST TIME BECAUSE I
SAW ON THE HOUSING BOARD AS WELL
AS WE WENT AND BUILT A FOUR PLEX
INSIDE THE CITY LIMITS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE NEVER DONE
BEFORE.
YOU KNOW -- JUST BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE.
PLACES AND STUFF ON ON THE
RESERVATION THAT WAS READY TO
BUILD AND WE NEEDED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT QUIRK.
SO REGIONAL SOME TO WITH THE
TAXES AND STUFF AS WELL YOU KNOW --
I MYSELF SIGNED OVER THIRTY FIVE
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
PERMITS AND STUFF TO BUILD THIS.
THE STOP FOUR PLEX SUNUNU'S
WHILE YOU EITHER A LITTLE UNDER
A LITTLE OVER AMILLION DOLLARS.
BUT IT WAS FOR YOU KNOW OUR OUR
YOUNGER GENERATION KIDS THAT ARE
GOING TO SCHOOL THAT.
DON'T -- MEET QUALIFICATIONS TO
BE UP ON THE HILL WHERE WE HAVE
A FOR SMALL FAMILIES AND WHAT.
YOU ALSO TO MEET THAT WAS HUGE
BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW I I JUST WANT
TO PUT THAT IS THAT WE DON'T
GIVE PER CAPITA OUT OF THIS.
IN IN OUR CASINOS NOT GOING TO
BE GETTING ANY BIGGER BECAUSE WE
DID DO A SURVEY.
IT ALL -- BECAUSE WE'RE ONLY
EIGHTY MILES FROM RENO NEVADA.
YOU KNOW SO WE'RE JUST KEEPING
THIS ALL LOCAL.
ARM.
IT ALSO SO AGAIN YOU KNOW I'VE I
THINK MY BIGGEST THING IS IS
WHAT I SAID ON THE TRIBAL
COUNCIL IS IS YOU KNOW SELF
SUFFICIENCY FOR MEMBERS.
ON IN EDUCATION YOU JUST CAN'T
GO WRONG AND EDUCATION.
SO THAT'S JUST ONE LECTURES ON
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC.
COMMENT.
THERE ARE TWO LETTERS THE
QUESTION HOUSING YOU HAD
MENTIONED THAT YOU'RE BUILDING A
FOUR PLEX OUTSIDE THE
RESERVATION IN THE COMMUNITY.
IS THAT FOR TRIBAL MEMBERS TO
LIVE THERE OR THAT OPEN.
THE GENERAL PUBLIC FOR TRIBAL
MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
AND THAT IS ON THAT IS ON FEE
LAND.
WE WEREN'T WE WILL NEVER PUT
THAT LAND INTO.
TRUST THAT IS WE PAY THE TAXES
ON IT YOU KNOW AND DO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IN THE COMMUNITY.
GOOD WELL THAT CONCLUDES -- THIS
PORTION OF THE COMPACT HEARING
THIS NAME MARK THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE -- MR RUBIN THANK YOU
AND CHAIR WOMAN FEEL BETTER.
THIS.
MEETING IS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
YOUR